there aren't many predators as majestic
as the tiger and there may be none as
difficult to find in the wild there are
only five kinds of tigers left on the
planet down from eight just a century
ago entire populations continue to
decline when Tigers in humans meet the
results are often deadly for one or the
other the National Geographic
photographer Nick Nichols has a special
reverence for the big cats and Nick
hopes that by showing the world the
power and majesty of these beasts he can
help build a political will to protect
them we really wanted to just find a way
to get into their world at such a secret
world nick has settled on a novel
approach he plans to capture a tiger on
film by taking himself out of the
picture he will set up a series of
remote video and still cameras in
India's vandag our national park this
first challenge is finding some Tigers
for that Nick and his assistant boy top
are getting some help from the local
elephant population and from their guide
nan de Rana
and by the end of the first week there
are camera traps all over the park on
Tiger trails near water holes even in
some places you wouldn't expect so we're
gonna set up a camera in this case
someone gets really hot he might come in
here to get out of the heat but the
camera will be here like six weeks and
if we get to two tigers will be happy
one he's coming down when an animal
crosses the infrared beam it triggers
the cameras Tigers can come at all hours
so they spend a lot of time making sure
the lighting will work 24 hours a day
trying to find a way to take pictures
Tigers on their terms you know exactly
the Tigers are taking their own picture
that's what it gets down to
while he's waiting for the traps to work
Nick bills a blind in the hopes he'll
capture a tiger in action
Wow they might understand what it dags
from predator like this but he doesn't
get the shots he's dreamed up he has
better luck tracking a mother Tiger from
the back of an elephant when I see her
it just makes me shake there's so much
adrenaline I can't keep my camera off of
her she's so beautiful with Nick nearby
she brings the kill to her growing Cubs
it's an exhilarating moment but what
about the hidden cameras a few weeks
after setting them up Roy goes to check
the traps he's on foot in Tiger country
that can be risky he does you're a loud
bitch right there but that is there's a
deer in this area called Cheadle and
when did they see a tiger that's what
they scream out so so we listen for
alarm calls we know there's a tiger in
the area and it's pretty close real
close unbeknownst to Roy but caught on
film by the hidden cameras a tiger
approaches a nearby pool for an
afternoon dip
Roy finds evidence the tiger is closed
some believable it's the last half
kilometer we've seen cry 15 to 20 scrape
markings of this Tiger the tiger here's
the men approach chugga-chugga and runs
off before they arrive Roy never sees
the tiger but believes one may have been
in the pool it have been recently some
lucky but this is a lot of water so no
no I would think he was just in here not
too long ago it's a lot of water out
here whoa bingo 55 triggers Tyrell yeah
honey it's gonna be good video back at
the tent the photographer's savor their
success come on please maybe this whole
go in oh my god yes yes come on Oh drink
oh man
this is too cool the tiger is caught by
Nick straps appear to ignore the cameras
flashes and clicking shutters
Nick hopes these unique images Tigers in
their natural state will convey the
beauty of these magnificent beasts and
help promote his call to protect them
and so you hope that the photographs
have to take might have something to do
with the continuation of wild tigers not
the continuation of tigress poison of
wild tigers these are rare images of an
even rarer creature a tiger in the Y